let's say that we have a ball that we
drop from a height of 10 meters and
every time it bounces it goes half as
high as the previous bounce so for
example you drop it from 10 meters the
next time it's peak height is going to
be at 5 meters so the next time around
on the next bounce let me draw R injure
and the next bounce the ball is going to
go 5 meters this distance right over
here is going to go it's going to be 5
meters and then the bounce after that is
going to be half as high this is going
to go two and a half meters is two and a
half meters and it's just going to keep
doing that and it's just going to keep
doing that so it's going to go two and a
half meters right over here and what I
want to think about in this video is
what is the total vertical distance that
the ball travels so let's think about
that a little bit so it's first going to
travel its first going to travel 10
meters straight down so it's going to
travel 10 meters just like that and then
it's going to travel half of 10 meters
twice it's going to go it's going to go
up five meters up half of 10 meters and
then down half of 10 meters so then it's
so it's going to go it's going to go two
times let me put it this way too so it's
going to go each of these is going to be
10 meters 10 meters I don't have to
write the unit's here let me take the
unit's out of the way so let me write
the clear so the first bounce once again
it goes straight down 10 meters then on
the next bounce it's going to go up ten
times one half and then it's going to go
down ten times one half ten times one
half notice we just care about the total
vertical distance we don't care about
the direction so it's going to go up ten
times one half up five meters and then
it's going to go down five meters this
it's going to travel a total vertical
distance of 10 meters five up and five
down now what about on this jump are on
this bounce I should say well here it's
going to go half as far as it went there
so it's going to go it's going to go
times 1/2 squared up and then 10 times
1/2 squared 10 times 1/2 squared down
and I think you see a pattern here this
looks an awful lot like a geometric
series an infinite geometric series it's
going to just keep on going like that
forever and ever so let's try to X me
let's try to clean this up a little bit
so it looks a little bit more like a
traditional geometric series so if we
were to simplify this a little bit we
could rewrite this as 10 plus plus 20 20
to the tie or 20 times 1/2 to the what
first power plus 10 1/2 times 1/2
squared plus 10 times 1/2 squared is
going to be 20 times 1/2 times 1/2
squared and we'll just keep on going on
and on so this would have this would be
a little bit clearer if this were a 20
right over here but we could do that we
could rewrite negative 10 oh sorry we
could write 10 as negative 10 plus 20
and then we have plus all of this stuff
right over here plus all of this so I'm
just copy and paste that copy and paste
so plus plus all of this right over here
and we can even write this first we can
even write this 20 right over here is 20
times 1/2 to the 0 power 20 times 1/2 to
the 0 power plus all of this so now it
very clearly looks like an infinite
geometric series we can write our entire
sum and maybe I'll write it up here
since I don't want to lose the diagram
we could write it as negative 10 that's
that negative 10 right over here plus
the sum from k is equal to zero to
infinity of 20 20 times our common ratio
our common ratio to the K power so
what's this going to be what's this
going to turn out to be well we've
already derived in multiple videos
already here that
the sum of an infinite geometric series
so the sum from k equals 0 to infinity
of a times R to the K is equal to a over
1 minus R so we just apply that right
over here this business right over here
is going to be equal to 20 over 1 minus
1/2 which is the same thing as 20 over
1/2 which is the same thing as 20 times
2 or 40 so how what's the total vertical
distance that our ball travels it's
going to be negative 10 plus 40 which is
equal to 30 meters our total vertical
distance that the ball travels is 30
meters